[Musique]
Véronique prince Michel David Christian
Dufour bonsoir bonsoir pour nous c'est
des journées importantes on aime
regarder l'écouter chaque mot qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire qu'est-ce que ça veut
pas dire
je vous fais entendre deux extraits sur
l'immigration le déclin du français qui
est un des vecteurs importants du
discours là on écoute et on revient
en matière d'identité
l'objectif
c'est carrément d'arrêter le déclin du
français au Québec en particulier à
Montréal
d'inverser la tendance parce que la
langue française c'est la base de notre
identité comme nation et ça doit être un
devoir
impératif
c'est important de se dire que
l'immigration c'est pas une solution
miracle ça fait partie du coffre à
outils mais on a je le disais tantôt
aussi le défi de concilier ça avec la
survie la protection
l'expansion du français au Québec
si on veut résumer Véronique d'un côté
son obsession pour reprendre le mot du
rattrapage économique et on inclut
là-dedans lutte au GES et tout ça parce
que c'est une occasion économique dit-il
de venir la batterie etc bon et de
l'autre c'est le français là c'est pas
mal les deux les deux éléments
essentiels de ce discours non oui il les
avait identifié d'ailleurs hier comme
les deux grands défis que lui comme
premier ministre finalement il veut
relever premièrement il veut que dans
les livres d'histoire son nom soit
associés à l'économie verte une espèce
de révolution finalement et il va être
associé à ça ce qui va permettre selon
lui de réduire les corps de richesse
avec l'Ontario et qui dit réduction de
l'écart de richesse fait en sorte
qu'après ça on en a plus dans nos poches
on a les moyens de nos ambitions bon ça
c'est une chose l'autre chose c'est
qu'effectivement François Legault a
besoin de démontrer encore une fois dans
son discours que le côté nationaliste
qu'il a tant martelé dans les derniers
mois c'est encore là et c'est encore au
cœur de ces préoccupations et selon lui
oui ça va passer par l'immigration
francophone et c'est important pour lui
de lancer les messages là-dessus par
contre on aura peut-être l'occasion de
dire venir là mais je serais très
curieuse d'entendre les discussions
autour de ça dans le conseil des
ministres parce que vous avez d'un côté
les peurs nationalistes les vrais bleus
qui vont dire oui on y va on protège le
français puis vous avez de l'autre côté
la frange plus économique qui vont dire
ouais on va protéger le français on est
d'accord on veut de l'immigration
francophone mais ça va rester jusqu'à
parka quand même et on le veut avec
perfid gibben aujourd'hui
tout Français il y a des exceptions si
j'ai besoin d'un Allemand pour réparer
ou créer une nouvelle machine je vais
aller le chercher l'allemand Michel
David de façon générale
comment comment vous avez comment vous
résumer la fresque que je répète c'est
une fresque assez large bah écoutez
très très excité à mon sens un discours
et c'est encore pire quand un
gouvernement entreprend un deuxième
mandat monsieur le Gaule l'avait dit
pendant la campagne ça va être la
continuité à continuer alors quand on
écoutait son discours inaugural à peu
près à chaque chapitre on va continuer à
faire si on va continuer à faire ça il y
a eu aucune annonce vraiment là qui va
dire ah voilà un nouveau grand projet
bon on va parler de barrage mais on
savait déjà que qu'il y aurait que
c'était dans les cartons du gouvernement
alors honnêtement j'ai pas été très
excité j'ai remarqué comme vous qu'il y
avait une insistance nouvelle ou accrue
disons sur le français et la question
des changements climatiques le débat qui
à venir au Conseil des ministres que
Véronique a évoquait il va être d'autant
plus intéressant que l'homme monsieur
fait du début dit exactement ce que
monsieur Legault lui-même disait il y a
trois ans à peine souvenez-vous au
moment de l'adoption de la loi 9 sur
l'immigration c'est Monsieur jalain
barrette qui était ministre à l'époque
le grand enjeu c'était précisément
d'arriver
l'immigration au besoin du marché du
travail et ceux qui comme le PQ disaient
non non faut que ça soit des
francophones au départ qui entre en
connaissant au Québec en connaissant
déjà le français c'est le logo disait
ben non voyons ça a pas de bon sens
alors c'est disons que les
l'évolution évoluent comme déjà dit un
ministre libéral parce que sur
l'immigration il y a un changement de
vocabulaire chez monsieur Legault c'est
plus un problème c'est plutôt même un
beau défi d'amener des gens qui parlent
français etc Christian de façon générale
c'était long hein
tellement de mesures il y avait
tellement de choses il y avait tellement
de parole en définitive bon on peut en
dégager quand même quelques thèmes
majeurs mais ça devrait quand même
l'impression de bon père de famille
parce que le goût a beaucoup cette image
là d'un gouvernement aidant extrêmement
présent
et moi je vois un peu d'argent
irresponsabilisation de la population
dans ce genre de discours là parce que
on est dans la sécurité on est dans le
positif bon mais si je veux focaliser
sur les points qui m'ont frappé
l'immigration c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant parce que oui un changement
de temps puis c'est heureux bon il est
revenu sur le chemin Roxane puis ça il
faut revenir sur le chemin je trouve que
tous les intervenants Québec devraient
revenir sur le chemin Roxane c'est un
scandale absolu et c'est majeur c'est
des dizaines de milliers de gens qui ont
ici qui sont à Montréal actuellement
puis qu'on a pas mais par contre il y a
admis que le Québec en fait faisait pas
ses devoirs dans ce dossier là ça c'est
très important pensons juste au milieu
Ottawa faisait passer non le Québec
aussi je trouve que possible
d'argent qui viennent d'Ottawa pour la
francisation des immigrants qui sont pas
utilisés que par le système qui a
quelque chose c'est un gros scandale
c'est beau de taper sur Ottawa je dis
pas qu'il faut pas contester Ottawa puis
Ottawan responsabilité sur chemin Roxane
mais le Québec une compétence réelle
là-dedans puis le Québec est pas assez
efficace il ne fait pas assez son
travail maman est-ce que c'est ce que
j'ai Dieu aussi dans son message que je
le répète là il y a vraiment j'ai pas
les montants en tête précisément mais il
y a des sommes énormes qui ne viennent
d'Ottawa pour France des immigrants pour
les utilise pas ok comment ça se fait
donc je sais que j'étais en effet
une heure 17 minutes pour être exact
puis il y a des gens qui pourront dire
Michel David il y avait pas beaucoup
d'éléments nouveaux il y avait pas
d'éléments nouveaux on arrive d'une
campagne et tout et je vous fais
entendre son obsession et il en parle
c'est écart de richesse avec l'Ontario
ça revient encore une fois on l'écoute
c'est qu'on est passé quand on regarde
notre écart de richesse avec l'Ontario
qui est une province qui ressemble plus
au Québec parce qu'on va convenir que
certaines provinces de l'Ouest qui
produisent du pétrole c'est difficile à
comparer donc on avait un écart en 2018
de 16.4% on est rendu à 12.8% qui
Ontario ça a l'air de rien mais on a
gagné
3,6 points en 4 ans c'est vraiment un
pas dans la bonne direction
alors je répète ce qu'il a voulu poser
c'est un lien entre la lutte contre les
GES et le développement économique ils
ont un avantage Michel David c'est
l'hydroélectricité je veux des barrages
genre un débat là-dessus et suivez-moi
parce qu'on a besoin d'une
demi-hydro-québec oui tout à fait ça
c'est un des bas qui a déjà commencé qui
va se poursuivre bien évidemment au
cours des prochaines années mais le lien
que Monsieur le gaufre entre les deux
c'est intéressant parce que
éventuellement il va y avoir un conflit
disons entre les développeurs et ceux
qui dans la priorité et de combattre les
GES et je pense que monsieur fait du
Gabin là-dedans va être extrêmement
actif et j'ai trouvé que et vous l'avez
remarqué un peu plus tôt dans la journée
n'est pas triste il y a eu un changement
de discours dans l'immigration dans la
bouche du gouvernement le goût on ne
réclame plus les nouveaux pouvoirs du
gouvernement fédéral là on se dit on
peut
faire avec ce qu'on a mais alors
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire avec ce qu'on a
à ce qu'on va prioriser des des
immigrants économiques pour continuer à
réduire le l'écart avec l'Ontario ou si
au contraire il va falloir
mettre l'accent sur la priorité du
français qui est à disons mettre un
petit peu moins l'accent sur sur la
diminution de l'écart alors tout se lit
un moment donné mais vous avez raison le
souligner en soulignait tout à l'heure
monsieur Legault ne demande plus en fait
je dis plus qu'il demande plus mais
publiquement aujourd'hui n'a pas demandé
100% des pouvoirs il dit il faut qu'on
s'entende avec le fédéral pour par
exemple les étudiants étrangers
francophones que le fédéral arrête de
mettre des bâtons dans un groupe qui
rentre parce qu'un changement
je trouve dans le débat sur
l'immigration c'est que quand on est de
plus en plus conscient que le 50000 dont
tout le monde parle c'est juste une
partie en fait du dossier il y a 40000
immigrants supplémentaires qui sont des
travailleurs temporaires puis il faut
que le gouvernement logo travaille
là-dessus parce que certains pouvoir une
certaine façon de penser là-dessus je
trouve que la façon dont tu réussis
comment je pourrais dire ça à traiter de
l'immigration un dossier qui ne
l'intéressait pas beaucoup au départ il
faut être réaliste il y a 4 ans il en
parlait pratiquement pas c'est quand
même intéressant puis moi ce que j'aime
comme québécois c'est qui sort d'un
certain masochisme ou les gens qui sont
juste dans l'idéologie environnementale
voudrait pas qu'on se rend compte du
fait que on bénéficie de l'hydraulique
on bénéficie du fait que nous nous les
prédécesseurs les gens de la Révolution
tranquille en fait ont investi dans un
capital hydroélectrique puis qu'on peut
en profiter ça je trouve ça intéressant
ce que le goût dit l'assumer pour le
reste moi ce qui m'a un peu dérangé je
trouve que trop de parole il y a trop
d'affaires là puis il y a de parler des
résultats il va falloir le juger sur les
résultats c'est bon les paroles prenez
la santé un discours inaugural par 23
ans
j'ai aimé votre beau-frère
je vais vous faire sourire
il a pas dit le mot troisième bien mais
à parler du tunnel Québec les villes
plein il dit extraordinaire il dit je
sens que les gens les ont compris ils
sont avec moi dans le fond il y a un
consensus sur écoute
je t'ai commentaire
sur le tunnel Québec lui semble je sens
certains consensus au moins pour les
deux voix sur quatre pour le transport
en commun je sens consensus on avance on
avance c'est important que
[Musique]
qu'on soit capable d'avoir du transport
collectif centre ville de Lévis à
centre-ville de Québec et de centre
ville de Québec à centre ville de Lille
on va finir par convaincre ceux qui
étaient plus difficiles à convaincre
il se sent un peu porté par les
résultats Véronique et quand même pas un
état de faiblesse là Monsieur le groupe
porté par le résultat il en fait même
des blagues vous allez voir vous allez
mais vous allez faire
ce boulot je l'ai quand même trouvé
particulier parce qu'habituellement un
discours d'ouverture on a beau trouver
selon trouver que ça s'en va dans tous
les sens la réalité c'est que ça
s'adresse pas à nous en fait le discours
d'ouverture ça s'adresse même pas aux
citoyens ça s'adresse aux ministres en
fait c'est des messages qui lancent au
ministre parce que là il leur dit je
veux des résultats en éducation je veux
des résultats aussi bon mais là il y a
fait d'une parenthèse puis le message il
l'a adressé aux parties de position
c'est clairement à eux finalement le
Yann a un consensus devrait vous joindre
donc c'est quand même particulier puis
le mot résultat effectivement il le
répétait vraiment plusieurs reprises il
y a beaucoup inscrit là-dessus et quand
je dis que c'est des messages assez
ministres je note que c'est quand même
il l'avait pas fait en 2018 vous allez
me dire que ça plus régulièrement qu'un
premier ministre fait des réunions avec
ses ministres puis leur demande bon
c'est quoi tes objectifs et tout ça mais
cette année avant le discours
d'ouverture il y avait beaucoup
d'enfants sur ces rencontres là il est
twitté il est publiait mais il mettait
ça partout sur les réseaux sociaux pour
dire regarder je suis en train de
rencontrer les ministres un à la fois
pour leur dire voici ce que je m'attend
de toi donc il veut montrer son côté
plus gestionnaire je trouve moi j'ai
trouvé ça aujourd'hui dans son discours
d'ouverture et puis il emprunte le style
en fait il a son style c'est pas lui
parce qu'il y a des discours des fois
c'est un peu on veut on veut faire de
grandes phrases il y a quand même style
Churchill au début la même courte phrase
Michel Cesson c'est il veut parler oui à
ces ministres mais aussi au Québec très
con qu'en disant dans le fond en disant
quoi je suis pragmatique je suis un
premier et même vis-à-vis Ottawa
j'adoucis le temps un peu Michel parce
que c'est oui en immigration mais même
en santé il y a pas de déchirer sa
non il n'y a pas déchiré sa chemise mais
il y a quand même il y a quand même
revenu avec insistance sur la nécessité
en disant écoutez les les dépenses des
provinces ça augmente de 5-6% en santé
et
Ottawa dans quelques années va se
retrouver encore une fois en période de
d'abondance fiscale alors que les
provinces vont avoir presque le couteau
sous la gorge alors ça j'ai trouvé qu'il
y avait quand même plus sa ligne mais le
côté bonhomme de monsieur Legault je
pense que votre anecdote à propos du
troisième lien était tout à fait
savoureuse parce que dans le fond le
consensus c'est peut-être que Bernard
Drainville est devenu un partisan du 3e
année mais au-delà de ça on n'a pas
senti un grand mouvement dans l'opinion
publique en faveur du troisième lien
pendant et depuis la campagne mais ça
montre qu'il est assez dégagé maintenant
qui peut il peut en Christian ouais
c'est vrai c'est une de ces forces en
fait son sens de l'humour en fait il va
rire de lui-même même parfois
ça allait être puis pour être
pragmatique ils sont pragmatiques ça pas
de doute là-dessus donc saint François
Legault on est face à un premier
ministre en fait que son style que sa
façon le gouverner je pense que
Véronique je trouve que c'est juste que
le différé c'est qu'on avait
l'impression qu'il s'adressait à ce
ministre parce qu'il regardeait puis
vous faut que vous fassiez ça vous
fassiez ça que vous fassiez ça donc nous
les Québécois ils s'adresse un petit peu
à nous quand même ben on va attendre les
résultats là c'est même pas contagieux
mais qu'est-ce que ça va donner
concrètement puis sur la langue on
semble que monsieur Legault a une vraie
inquiétude au chef de langue ça c'est
une bonne nouvelle parce que c'est vrai
que c'est inquiétant mais notant qui
bouge pas dans le dossier de la loi 101
au cégep alors qu'un large large
consensus ambassade d'éducation qu'on
devrait le faire ça sera un changement
structurant qui qui changerait les
choses pour le reste il propose quoi
concrètement Roxane ma part ça d'avoir
plus d'immigration francophone c'est
plus facile à dire qu'à faire faudrait
pas oublier non plus c'est pas c'est pas
une politique précise une annonce sur
cette espèce de cette vision que lutter
contre les GES ça peut être aussi faire
croire que l'économie c'est ça qui
voulait passer
concrètement ça va donner quoi puis sur
la langue parce que ici sur la langue
c'est son premier rôle comme premier
ministre du Québec sur la marque moi je
suis un peu déçu parce que qu'est-ce qui
nous a dit qu'il fallait avoir plus
d'immigration francophone bon bonne
chance parce que suite à faire réaliste
faudrait pas perdre aussi les
francophones les gens qui parlent des
langues latines des Italiens les
Espagnols donc écoutez je trouve que
c'est un discours trop long moi je les
tours du moment donné puis là il faut
l'attendre dans le domaine du concret ça
serait trop facile pour notre premier
ministre sur la langue un petit bon
Michel Véronique sur le fait que là
aussi comment santé il y a cette
obsession des données des seuils des
chiffres il veut qu'au Québec on
n'attendent pas aux cinq ans alors
comment ça pourra se faire est-ce que
c'est pas avec le rapport d'impôts par
exemple ce qu'on va ajouter une question
je pense que c'est dans les vendeurs du
futur commissaire à de la langue
française de faire le suivi de
l'évolution un peu comme on demandait à
l'office que québécois de la langue
française je pense pas qu'on va avoir
des données là aussi précises que celles
des recensements de Statistiques Canada
j'ai l'impression que ça va être plutôt
soit des études ponctuelles soit des
compilations de statistiques déjà
existantes mais je pense pas qu'on va
doubler cette Canada je pense monsieur
Lego voulait donner l'impression qu'il
serait plus vigilant
à l'avenir mais je pense pas qu'il nous
annonce
avec le rapport d'impôts autrement on
devra remplir un questionnaire de
recensement tous les quatre ans tous les
ans
on sait pas tout parce qu'en réalité on
attend encore on nous dit qu'il y a un
plan costaud qui va être déposé par
Jean-François Roberge justement sur
cette question là mais ce plan-là on en
a pas vu une ligne nulle part il y a
rien qui est cool encore et
Jean-François auberge à ma connaissance
n'a pas non plus donné d'entrevue encore
aucun parler de sa vision donc on peut
supposer que ça va peut-être se
retrouver là dedans bon conclusion alors
demain matin il en reste quoi
de ce discours
viens je commence avec vous Véronique
est-ce qu'il a d'un point de vue
stratégique est-ce que il a coché les
cases qu'il devait cocher mais en fait
il a coché pas mal toutes les cases
parce que il y a pas un sujet qui a pas
abordé où on s'est dit ah ça il y en a
pas vraiment parlé là mais je note quand
même et je voyais dans l'entrevue avec
Gabriel Nadaud Dubois aussi qu'il notait
la même chose que François Lebeau a
quand même beaucoup plus parler
d'environnement cette fois-ci si on fait
la comparaison avec son discours
d'ouverture en 2018 et c'est pas pour
rien qu'il parle davantage environnement
oui il lit ça une économie verte puis on
peut générer des revenus et tout ça mais
en même temps j'ai entendu souvent dans
les coccus de députés dans les conseils
de ministres que les enfants des
ministres des ados des jeunes adultes
des trentenaires qui leur vous parlez
pas assez d'environnement la pression
leur est venue de leur entourage aussi
Michel David je pense que à partir de
demain on va on va retomber dans le
quotidien et dans le concret la langue
française
US et tout le monde s'entend que c'est
capital mais c'est du long terme là à
partir de la semaine prochaine on va
voir la mise à jour on va se recommencer
à parler des méfaits de l'inflation on
va recommencer à parler des problèmes de
santé alors ça va être beaucoup plus
terre à terre comme préoccupation je
pense à partir de demain Christian 20
secondes au fond je trouve c'était pas
un discours inaugural qui s'adressait à
la population comme Véronique le dit il
y a coché toutes les cases mais là ce
serait peut-être bon là qu'on sache ça
il focalise sur quoi fondamentalement
sur quoi il va falloir les juger je
trouve que trop d'affaires dans ce
discours là mais nous les Québécois là
faut s'attendre à quoi de ce
gouvernement là Véronique Michel
Christian a très bientôt bonne soirée
merci au revoir